-My first guest is a Tony,
Oscar, and Grammy-winning
music legend who has sold over
300 million records worldwide.
Holy moly. 300 million.
[ Cheers and applause ]
His new album, "The Lockdown
Sessions," is out now.
Please welcome the one and only
Elton John!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoa!
That's what I'm talking about!
Yes!
Ah, it's so good to see you.
-Thank you.
Lovely to see you, Jimmy.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
I know you're in London.
So I appreciate you Zooming in
and talking to me.
I just want to tell you
how much I love
the album,
"The Lockdown Sessions."
And congrats on having
a number 1 with Dua Lipa.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're always doing something
different and I just love --
You know I'm a big fan,
but I love when you get together
with Dua and that came out,
I go, "'Cold Heart'?
What is going on? This is, like,
the coolest thing ever."
And you didn't even
get to the --
♪ It's no sacrifice ♪
You didn't even do that.
-Nope.
-No.
-No, we cut that bit out.
-Yeah, you didn't need it.
You just had "cold, cold heart."
I go, "Ah."
I just loved it so much.
Congrats.
-Thank you very much. Thank you.
-Did you know you were going to
put an album out?
-Listen, it all came about
by accident.
During lockdown, I was
in this house in Windsor
in England with my family,
with the kids and David.
And the last thing I thought
I was going to do
is make any music.
And then people asked me
to start playing
and singing on
their own records,
which I -- you know,
that's how I started out.
I was a session guy
before I became Elton.
So I played on a Rina Sawayama,
a Gorillaz thing, a Metallica,
Miley Cyrus track,
Glen Campbell, Lil Nas X,
Years & Years,
and I thought, "I like this."
I like this, going back to
where I used to be.
-Yeah. Then you're like, "Why
don't you come on my album?"
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Well, when I did the Lil Nas X,
Glen Campbell,
I was in Studio 2 at Abbey Road.
And 54 years, practically to
the day, I was playing piano
on The Hollies' "He Ain't Heavy,
He's My Brother."
So that's kind of a nice feeling
to have.
-That is pretty cool.
I was surprised to find out
but I guess it's true that --
'cause Stevie Wonder is on here.
Everybody is on this album,
by the way.
This is an awesome gift,
Because if you're like,
"Oh, yeah, I love --"
Obviously, I love Elton John,
but if you love Stevie Wonder --
You guys have never done a duet
together.
-No, we've never done a duet.
And we've known each other
for so long.
And so, when I wrote this song,
I suddenly thought there's
a harmonica solo here.
And then he came
and played piano.
And then we put drums and bass
and then the choir.
And in the end, he sang on it.
And it's a dream come true
for me
because, you know, not only do
I love him as a musician
and worship him as a songwriter,
but he's one of my favorite
people in the whole wide world.
So this was a very exciting
thing for me.
-I have a photo here from 1973.
And I think there's a cool story
behind it.
Do you remember where this was
or what this was?
-I do remember.
It's not one of my brightest
and most wonderful moments.
I was on "The Starship," which
was a jet that we were renting.
I had just done a show.
It was birthday.
And I wasn't happy with
the show.
So I went up front
and sat on my own.
And they said,
"Come up to the bow.
We want to sing 'Happy Birthday'
to you."
And I went, "I'm not interested
in my birthday."
And this happened about
three or four times until
my publicist burst into tears
and said,
"You have to come up there.
Stevie Wonder is at the organ."
Of course, the plane
had an organ on it.
[ Laughter ]
"And he wants to sing
'Happy Birthday' to you."
And I felt such a horror.
I felt so bad
and I went up there,
and he sang "Happy Birthday"
to me.
And it's an incident
I will never forget,
and as I say,
I'm not very proud of.
-No, yeah, but it's still cool
that, first of all,
the name of the private plane
was called "The Starship."
I love that, and then the fact
that you have a --
of course you have
a piano on the plane
or an organ on the plane.
-Yeah.
-That's pretty rad.
Have you ever surprised anyone
with a happy birthday?
By singing them
a "Happy Birthday" song?
-I can't remember.
I must have in my life.
But Stevie actually sang
"Happy Birthday" to me
at my 70th birthday as well,
along with Lady Gaga,
Ryan Adams, and Rosanne Cash.
So, I mean, I've been very lucky
in that respect.
And at my 60th birthday,
Tony Bennett,
the Scissor Sisters,
and Mary J. Blige.
So I've been quite lucky
with people singing to me,
but I'm not very good
at singing birthdays.
I haven't really sung at
anybody else's birthday party,
but I've had lots of people
singing to me.
So I'm very lucky.
-Yeah.
Mine's coming up September.
[ Laughter ]
So I will just...
-Okay.
-...throw it out there,
and we'll see where you're at.
-Well, just give me an e-mail
and I'll see where I am.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, no problem.
You know, last time we talked,
I was talking about how you
always are into new music.
And you're always supporting
new artists,
which you do as well on this,
not only Dua Lipa,
but also you have Young Thug
on here.
You always know about music
before it comes out,
which is opposite of me.
I'm going backwards.
I'm just finding old music
and going like,
"Have you guys heard this song?"
And everyone's like, "Yeah,
it came out 30 years ago."
But how do you stay up to date
and why has it become
a cool new tradition for you?
You've been calling
all these people
and just saying hi
and that you're a fan.
-Well, I do a radio show
on Apple
every week for six years now.
Every week for six years,
called "The Rocket Hour."
And during that hour,
I try and play new music that
hasn't been played before.
And so, you know,
I get to hear new music,
and then when I love something,
I have the person on
to interview them
and I get to know them.
On the album, there's Olly
Alexander from Years & Years,
Rina Sawayama,
Surfaces, and SG Lewis.
And I've gotten to be friends
with all these artists.
You know,
ever since I was a kid,
I've been a fan,
and I love records.
And I know the new.
I know the old.
But I'm more interested in
the new
because that's what's going to
take music further.
And a lot of these people
don't get enough exposure
because radios have
so many definite playlists
and these songs don't fit in.
And so if I can get a chance
to promote them
and then be friends with them
and then play with them
and record with them,
then it's fantastic for me.
-Do you stay friends with --
[ Applause ]
Absolutely.
That's why you're the -- Do you
stay in touch with these people?
Do you actually stay friends
with them?
-Yeah, yesterday,
I rang Teyana Taylor,
who was a guest on my show
a year and a half ago.
I did a video with her
because we became friends.
Yes, I do, and I think it's
really good and it's important.
Jimmy, when I came to America,
I had so much kindness
shown towards me by
Brian Wilson, the Beach Boys,
Neil Diamond, Leon Russell,
the Beatles,
Bob Dylan, Linda Ronstadt,
The Band,
and that made me feel so good.
It kind of ratified
what I was doing.
And so I always thought I must
carry on that tradition
of being, if you like something,
tell the person that it's good.
It doesn't have to be
a musician.
Could be a photographer,
a painter, an actor, whatever.
But if it gives you pleasure
and it makes you feel good,
then ring them up and tell them.
-Yeah, I love that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
More with Elton John
after the break.
We're going to talk about
his tour. Come on back.